so retten wir leben sagt die
bundeskanzlerin und ruft zu verzicht und
opfern auf in der korona krise es gibt
ein weitgehendes kontaktverbot im ganzen
land italien fährt die wirtschaft
herunter im verzweifelten kampf gegen
immer mehr infektionen sollen erst mal
alle firmen und fabriken im land dicht
machen lebenswichtige betriebe und
supermärkte sind davon ausgenommen
und hilfe aus der nachbarschaft
rheinland pfalz das saarland und baden
württemberg nehmen corona patienten aus
völlig überlasteten kliniken in
frankreich auf
nachrichten nicht da es heute mit
christian sievers guten abend zu ihrem
nachrichtenüberblick ich freue mich sehr
dass sie alle auch heute dabei sind wir
haben 15 minuten vor allem natürlich für
die aktuelle entwicklung im kampf gegen
das corona virus bei uns in deutschland
wird das öffentliche leben landesweit
weiter deutlich heruntergefahren es
gelten strikte regeln für soziale
kontakte
das ist teil eines neuen verbots
katalogs auf denen sich die
ministerpräsidenten der länder mit der
bundeskanzlerin verständigt haben
angela merkel hat dazu vor eineinhalb
stunden neun punkte genannt und an alle
deutschen appelliert
erstens die bürgerinnen und bürger
werden angehalten die kontakte zu
anderen menschen außerhalb der
angehörigen des eigenen hausstandes auf
ein absolut nötiges minimum zu
reduzieren
zweitens in der öffentlichkeit ist wo
immer möglich zu anderen als den unter
eben genannten personen ein
mindestabstand von mindestens 1,5 meter
besser noch zwei meter einzuhalten
drittens der aufenthalt im öffentlichen
raum ist nur alleine mit einer weiteren
noch im haushalt lebenden personen also
eine weiteren im haushalt lebenden
personen oder im kreis der angehörigen
des eigenen hausstands gestattet
viertens der weg zur arbeit zur
notbetreuung einkäufe arztbesuche
teilnahme an sitzungen erforderlichen
terminen und prüfungen hilfe für andere
individueller sport und bewegung an der
frischen luft sowie andere notwendige
tätigkeiten bleiben selbstverständlich
weiter möglich fünftens
gruppe feiernder menschen auf
öffentlichen plätzen in wohnungen sowie
privaten einrichtungen sind angesichts
der ernsten lage in unserem land
inakzeptabel
verstöße gegen die kontakt
beschränkungen sollen von
ordnungsbehörden und der polizei
überwacht und bei zuwiderhandlungen
sanktioniert werden
sechstens gastronomiebetriebe werden
geschlossen
davon ausgenommen ist die lieferung und
abholung mitnahme fähiger speisen für
den verzehr zu hause siebenten dies
dienstleistungsbetriebe im bereich der
körperpflege wie friseure
kosmetikstudios massagepraxen tattoo
studios und ähnliche betriebe werden
geschlossen weil sie in diesem bereich
eine körperliche nähe haben die ja
unabdingbar für die berufsausübung ist
und deshalb nicht zu den leitlinien die
wir uns gegeben haben passen medizinisch
notwendige behandlungen bleiben weiter
möglich achtens in allen betrieben und
insbesondere solche mit publikumsverkehr
ist es wichtig die hygienevorschriften
einzuhalten und wirksame schutzmaßnahmen
für mitarbeiter und besucher umzusetzen
und 9 diese maßnahmen sollen eine
geltungsdauer von mindestens zwei wochen
haben
frau bundeskanzlerin als er die
massnahmen vorgelesen haben haben sie
gesagt
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
nur alleine mit einer weiteren im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im kreis
der angehörigen des eigenen haushalts
gestattet ist es muss doch heißen damit
ein fehler
das habe ich dann einen fehler gemacht
da lese ich gleich noch mal vor damit
was alles richtig haben
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
nur alleine mit einer weiteren nicht im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im kreis
der angehörigen des eigenen hausstands
gestattet dann haben wir es noch mal
ganz perfekt die bundeskanzlerin heute
abend was das jetzt für die einzelnen
bundesländer heißt und wie sich die
menschen darauf einstellen dazu jetzt
cornelia schiemenz mit mehreren personen
den frühling genießen erst
einmal vorbei auch gemeinschaftliches
fußball spielen im park vorerst verboten
das gilt ab morgen bundesweit
wir verbieten also nicht gewogen zu
verlassen ist weiterhin möglich
lebensmittel einzukaufen zur arbeit zu
gehen falls home office nicht möglich
ist ein arzt aufzusuchen oder frische
luft zu schnappen
zwar würden sich die allermeisten
menschen in deutschland an die auflagen
halten doch noch immer gäbe es viel
unvernunft deshalb werden ansammlungen
von mehr als zwei personen verboten
verstöße werden wir hart verfolgen durch
empfindliche bußgelder bis zu 25.000
euro erleichtern und strafrechtliche
verfolgung bei schweren verstößen
es gelte das prinzip der
nulltoleranzpolitik nur so habe man eine
chance die korona pandemie einzudämmen
die alarmierende lage in anderen länder
der europäischen union und das
insbesondere in italien aber auch in
frankreich verdeutlicht von tag zu tag
mehr dass die lage sehr ernst ist es
geht letztlich um leben und tod
die menschen wie hier in hamburg
zwiegespalten so findet das richtig dass
ich so große gruppen zusammen sagen
würden man muss jetzt ein bisschen
rücksicht auf den pakt gegen nehmen ich
denke schon dass das funktionieren
könnte aber ich glaube nicht dass sich
sehr viele daran halten werden aber das
nennen das ist das für uns alle eine
neue situation und ich denke irgendwo
muss man anfangen ist es natürlich
schwierig den richtigen weg zu gehen
das kontaktverbot soll mindestens zwei
wochen gelten nachjustierungen nicht
ausgeschlossen dass die bundeskanzlerin
mit den ministerpräsidenten der länder
heute zusammenkommt energy in berlin
nicht in einem raum natürlich sondern
per video-konferenz wie viel einigkeit
war denn da dann tatsächlich zu spüren
wie stark wurde gerungen
es wurde gerungen es gab diskussionen
zum teil tatsächlich auch sehr lebhaft
dass man wir aus der runde gehört es gab
ja auch verschiedene modelle die da auf
dem tisch lagen bayern hatte zum
beispiel schon 1 vorgelegt andere
bundesländer hatten andere vorschläge
und da galt es eben heute sich
zusammenzuraufen
in der sache muss man sagen sind sich am
ende
einig gewesen es müssen gleiche regeln
für alle gelten in ganz deutschland das
ist jetzt beschlossen worden
das ganze wird auch unter strafe
gestellt also wer gegen diese regeln
verstößt muss mit sanktionen rechnen
darauf hat man sich heute geeinigt und
jetzt kam vor ein paar minuten die
nachricht dass auch die bundeskanzlerin
selbst in häusliche quarantäne muss was
ist der hintergrund
ja das ist eine nachricht die vom
regierungssprecher gekommen ist angela
merkel ist wohl am freitagnachmittag bei
einer pneumokokken impfung gewesen und
heute nach der pressekonferenz die wir
gerade eben auch gesehen haben soll sie
erfahren haben dass der arzt der sie
dort geimpft hat sich angesteckt hat mit
dem saas co2 virus sie selbst ist also
jetzt in einer vorsorglichen quarantäne
wird sich mehrfach testen lassen in den
kommenden tagen bis dann klarheit
darüber herrscht ob sie sich angesteckt
hat oder nicht das ist die nachricht die
dienstgeschäfte wird sie wie jetzt viele
mit anderen menschen momentan auch aus
dem homeoffice machen müssen
ich habe einen zdf berlin vielen dank
alle details zu den neuen plänen von
bund und ländern gibt es auch online bei
uns da können sie sämtliche punkte und
weitere erläuterungen was das jetzt für
das tägliche leben heißt noch mal
nachlesen auf heute de und in der heute
und jetzt der moment in der sendung an
dem wir auf die zahlen gucken müssen
zuerst bei uns in deutschland das virus
greift weiter um sich
stand 18 uhr 30 gibt es in deutschland
fast 24.000 infizierte die zahl der
toten hat sich auf 92 erhöht in vielen
ländern weltweit gehen die zahlen
deutlich nach oben am dramatischsten ist
die lage weiterhin in italien dort sind
allein in den letzten 24 stunden 651
menschen an corona infektionen gestorben
insgesamt zählt italien jetzt 5476 tote
und die regierung greift zu neuen noch
einschneidendere mitteln sie schließt
alle firmen und fabriken die nicht
überlebenswichtig sind aus rom annette
hilsenbeck särge stehen aufgereiht in
der kapelle des krankenhauses von
cremona im norden italiens opfer des
corona virus immer mehr sterben
die intensivstation sind überbelegt
ärzte und pflegekräfte am ende
[Musik]
es ist ein desaster
es ist ein tsunami und wir arbeiten
zwölf stunden am tag
[Musik]
angesichts der katastrophalen lage macht
die regierung nun einen bisher kaum
vorstellbaren schritt es ist die
schwierigste krise in der wir seit dem
krieg sind die regierung hat beschlossen
im ganzen land die
produktionsaktivitäten die nicht
lebensnotwendig sind zu schließen
damit bleiben etwa betriebe der
lebensmittelproduktion offen um die
supermärkte weiter zu versorgen auch
banken und energieversorger arbeiten
weiter maschinenbau oder möbel firmen
zum beispiel schließen genauso wie
baustellen
das trifft vor allem das wirtschaftliche
herz italiens die lombardei rund um
mailand trotz der sperr verordnung
liefen hier immer noch große teile der
produktion
gerade hier ist die zahl der todesopfer
und der neuinfektionen rapide gestiegen
weitaus höher als im rest des landes
nun soll in italien nur noch das
allernötigste in bewegung bleiben um die
verbreitung des virus endlich
einzudämmen
auch im nordosten von frankreich ist die
zahl der erkrankten sehr hoch im elsass
kommen die intensivstationen der
krankenhäuser an ihre grenzen
es fehlen vor allem beatmungs plätze für
schwerkranke hilfe kommt jetzt aus
rheinland pfalz aus dem saarland und aus
baden württemberg die deutschen nachbarn
wollen einige der schwer kranken aus
frankreich in ihre kliniken holen sven
class berichtet alles ist vorbereitet an
der uniklinik in heidelberg
es ist eines von drei intensiv zimmern
in das wohl in den nächsten stunden
corona patienten aus dem elsass
eingeliefert werden aus einer region die
besonders heftig unter den folgen der
korona pandemie leidet derzeit noch
entsprechenden kapazitäten die wir zur
verfügung stellen können und es ist uns
wichtig dass man unter freunden und
unter guten nachbarn sich hilft wenn es
darauf ankommt zehn patienten aus dem
benachbarten elsass nehmen die
baden-württembergischen
die kliniken zunächst auf wie hier die
uniklinik freiburg
auch in anderen kliniken im land läuft
eine abfrage ob intensivbetten
vorübergehend zur verfügung gestellt
werden können
die beatmungs zeigten sich um eine woche
handeln und dann hat sich das schicksal
des patienten in der regel entschieden
entweder es gelingt uns den patient zu
stabilisieren
oder er verstirbt dann leider im elsass
sind viele krankenhäuser derzeit nicht
mehr in der lage alle kopf 19 patienten
aus eigener kraft zu versorgen das
medizinische personal an der
belastungsgrenze
letzte woche haben wir drei patienten
den eineinhalb stunden verloren
wir haben in unserem beruf immer mit dem
tod zu tun aber dass jetzt die ganze
zeit zu sehen das ist hart sehr hart
in den letzten tagen wurden bereits
schwer kranke corona patienten aus dem
elsass durch die armee in andere gebiete
in frankreich geflogen jetzt helfen auch
die kliniken in deutschland
der dank der derpart morath präsidentin
per twitter auf deutsch die hilfe auch
eine geste des zusammenhalts an die
französischen nachbarn bei denen die
einseitige einführung von deutschen
grenzkontrollen vor knapp einer woche
für verstimmung gesorgt hatte gemeinsam
beten gibt vielen menschen kraft doch da
sich das corona virus ausbreitet und
größere gruppen zu meiden sind geht das
nicht in der kirche
bundesweit sind alle öffentlichen
gottesdienste abgesagt die alternative
sollen messen seien via telefon oder
internet ein besonderer sonntag marion
geiger wie jeden sonntag leuten die
domglocken in trier zum gottesdienst
doch niemand darf rein
die türen geschlossen corona
ausnahmezustand dennoch findet der
gottesdienst statt zu fünft in großem
abstand
für die gläubigen zu hause ist ein live
stream geplant der aber scheitert am
überlasteten mobilfunknetz die neue
situation gewöhnungsbedürftig vieles
erleben sich im moment eine größere
einsamkeit noch als sie sonst haben wir
entdecken aber auch in unseren vereinen
dass wir dass die leute kreativ werden
ob bischofskirche oder kleine pfarrei
viele bieten streams der heiligen messe
an und beten online
jetzt ist abstand das gebot der stunde
und es ist auch ein gebot der
nächstenliebe dass wir uns daran halten
des selbstschutzes und des schutzes vor
allem der besonders gefährdeten durch
ihn und mit ihm auch das zdf überträgt
gottesdienste jeden sonntag live
jederzeit abrufbar in der mediathek
trotz aller angebote manche vermissen
das miteinander ist ein ersatz für müsse
das kann richtig muss die gemeinde fehlt
einem einfach ne die die mit beeten
mitsingt und man ist ja allein dann
außerhalb der gottesdienste sind einige
kirchen noch geöffnet für ein stilles
gebet vereinzelter menschen in
schwieriger zeit so viel zunächst zur
corona epidemie und dann noch diese
nachricht heute in der kroatischen
hauptstadt zagreb hat heute morgen die
erde gebebt 17 menschen wurden verletzt
ein mädchen schwebt in lebensgefahr
durch die stöße der stärke 5,3 löste
sich an der gotischen kathedrale den
wahrzeichen der stadt eine der beiden
sturmspitzen
zwei kliniken mussten teilweise geräumt
werden kurze zeit später gab es noch ein
nachbeben das fast genauso stark war
es sind tage an denen viele und vieles
an grenzen geraten überall scheint die
welt aus den fugen und es ist
gleichzeitig eine zeit die zeigt wie
viel kleine gesten bedeuten gerade jetzt
ein 80 geburtstag in spanien inmitten
der ausgangssperre aber die nachbarn
haben nicht vergessen dass caro in
madrid heute ein rundes jubiläum feiert
und zwar eben doch nicht allein eine
torte und ein ständchen in diesem
mietshaus das zusammensteht ein wort
nachahmenswert das wetter morgen scheint
die sonne von einem meist tiefblauen
himmel aber es gibt viel wind und meist
nur mäßige temperaturen dazu ein bis
sieben grad im osten und 7 bis 12 grad
im westen
auch die nächsten tage werden sonnig bei
weiterhin böigem ostwind aber nur 1 bis
11 grad
um 21 uhr 55 hat marietta slomka das
heute-journal jetzt gleich nach uns ein
zdf spezial mit theo koll
das war die hauptausgabe der heute
nachrichten an diesem sonntag das sollte
man betonen in einer zeit in der die
tage scheinen zunehmend ineinander
überzugehen
wir alle danken für das interesse
wünschen ihnen wo immer das geht ein
angenehm haben